i think the challenges today is really
the world changes too fast
i mean look at the last year and a half
how much things have been changing day
by day
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i am joined by
song to vp of product management tata
communications
song is the vp of product management at
tata communications a global
telecommunications managed service
provider
he runs a global business connecting the
offices and users of multinational
enterprises
to their critical business applications
using the latest programmable network
and it infrastructure technology
at global companies like cisco and
telecommunications
song has delivered products that make
enterprise it infrastructure more agile
cost efficient and easy to use allowing
any customer
to focus on their business rather than
constrained by the complex technologies
they deployed
song bhakto thank you for joining me on
20 milliliters how are you today
i'm doing well thank you michael for
inviting me on the show
i'm excited to talk about agility in the
enterprise world
you've had you've held a numerous
positions in fantastic companies
whether it's a head of network
automation at cisco
but also currently vice president of
product management within
tata communications and and you know one
of the things that
i've been observing you know looking
over your journey is is this phenomena
of taking
you know enterprise processes and and
making them agile and
obviously we know today at this big
distance between the startup and
early stage ecosystem versus the big
large enterprises and the speeds that
they go at
so i'm excited to learn more about you
but also about this idea of agility
within the enterprise
so to get started who are you song who
are you
who am i yeah that's a good question
michael uh
as you said right as far as what i do
right now i'm the vp of product
management at tata communications
uh the line of business i manage is to
manage network services
right we offer connectivity services for
global enterprises
connecting their branches connecting
their users to applications
right these users are scattered around
the world connecting them is
more complicated than just hey i got
internet connection and everything is
fine
and i'm of course very excited to talk
about agility
uh yes what do i do so within tata what
do you do there yeah i write
i owned a p l right the profit and loss
of the business
there is a uh as far as connectivity is
concerned
when you connect a brand enterprise
branch to you know to the data center or
to the cloud
you have mpls which is a private network
with guaranteed connectivity
and internet right but internet is like
what you
you and i use from home but when you
connect multiple branches
across a long distance across you know
thousands of miles
the things becomes more complicated the
ability to
do zoom or do any sort of uh web
conferencing
could sometimes be impacted and when you
have thousands of users who are impacted
that can be quite painful
those loss of productivity means loss of
agility lots of uh you know
company profit and competitiveness
and we deliver that as a service right
to enterprises
so what does that actually mean to
deliver that as a service to enterprises
what does that actually get translated
yeah absolutely i think this is a
uh actually a starting point of you know
enterprise agility that we can talk
about here
an enterprise can obviously say i got a
hundred branches or a thousand branches
around the world
and these branches are in different
countries i'll go talk to different
service providers at t in the u.s and bt
in the uk
and maybe i have 50 service providers i
contract with
i get connectivity to my branches and i
set up you know
all these contracts and make sure
they're connected in a way that i need
to
i pay bills to all 50 providers every
month anything goes wrong i pursue them
for
service level agreement credits etc
we come in and say well we know this is
complicated too
for you and you really want to run your
business
rather than you know chasing people
paying bills to 50 different providers
and negotiating them for credit right
we'll ensure that you get connected
if you need to get partners involved
will get partners involved you get a
contract with us to
provide the connectivity from mpls
internet to sd-wan to cloud connect
right that's uh that's what i remember
as a service if you pay us monthly
you don't pay us a lump sum and then use
it for you know
20 years right now that makes a lot of
sense and so when you're talking about
you know working work as an enterprise
and whether it's tata communications or
or cisco or wherever that may be talk to
me a little bit about the the
the enterprise atmosphere the
environment the speed
and and why why there is this dissonance
between
you know startups and large enterprises
absolutely
michael yeah i have also worked with
startups right
built my own startups and then as well
as of course working at pretty mature
large company today
i think the challenges today is really
the world changes too fast
i mean look at the last year and a half
how much things have been changing
day by day right you can make plan the
best late plan goes
right now everybody agrees we got to be
agile we got to react quickly
but a lot of enterprise planning process
is such that
it wasn't agile let me take an example
of
how we move from you know building own
data center
private cloud to public cloud being so
prominent today
and then i can talk about how network as
a service become very interesting
in the past when you want to build a new
application you want to launch a new
business
so you need new applications to support
it you negotiate with the it
organization
and they say to give you a server to
build a prototype
i need six months build business case
for me
that just you know that thing is dragged
on right that's before you write a
single line of code
and when public cloud came in right um
the the developer said i can just go
build a prototype got a vm
in 15 minutes with a credit card i built
a prototype over the weekend
show the bosses they say great go do
this for three months
they haven't done this you know any
negotiation with it at that point
right of course in the beginning that
was considered
pharaoh and that was considered shadow
i.t but then
if all the people who are generating
revenue said i need this model of
operations
all right this is so the only way i can
build business as i need
and shut it down and stop paying if it
doesn't work
and so you know data center to cloud
that movement happen
network connectivity as well
increasingly people want network as a
service on demand
and especially for cloud connectivity
and data center connectivity they say
i cannot predict the bandwidth it will
grow i'm not going to negotiate today
and then buy the bandwidth i need
i need three years from now i'm going to
buy what i need now and what i need
more i'll get more and that's
you know the distance between
i guess you know plan once and use it
for n number of years
versus you know be able to get the
infrastructure
as a service and be flexible and that's
you know what
i've been in the business of
transforming the product portfolio to
enable that
and of course in the process help my
enterprise customers
right achieve the agility they need
right oftentimes we engage in a
conversation of
what do you really need to achieve and
what are the resources you need
how do we structure a i.t architecture
for you that allow you to achieve that
right without you spending 80 of your
time on it architecture
versus business innovation
put me you know in the room where it
happens put put me in the same table
as yourself with your enterprise
customers how does that conversation go
so
how do how how does this relationship
work
where you are coming in as sort of an
enabler and they are looking for ways
to either be more agile or they're just
trying to keep up with the with the
changing world
how does that conversation look like
yeah today i think michael
especially on the network side a lot of
the conversations about
i have built an architecture for network
that was
very very good when my applications were
in the data center
and they're not there anymore
in some cases some of the extreme cases
enterprises shut down all their data
centers they have no data center
traditional enterprise network is huff
and spoke there's a center of attention
where all the branches connect in
and there's an internet breakout to
connect to some sas applications
that's not there anymore they're saying
i cannot offer the performance my users
need
because my traffic all comes from the
edges into the data center and out
when that application might actually be
hosted next to the user
in the same city but those users get no
benefit because they all come back to
the data center
and the cost of the network using
private network mpls is also overly
expensive
how can you help me change that and
we say okay well where are your users
where are your branches
where are your applications going
i say going because it's not static
either it's not like
where are your applications today let me
design it for you
this actually is a dynamic changing
situation
so over that discussion we figure out
how they are moving that we design a
network architecture that's
suitable for that and offer them even
some level of self-control
so they can prioritize traffic improve
user experience right because notice
that when you're connecting to an
application
even zoom or some web conferencing and
things started getting jittery or
disrupted it could be a bandwidth issue
it could be a server easier
from a service provider side but it
could be a network issue
and there are ways to optimize that that
we offer
a service that's managed to optimize
those experience
right now when you're sitting with your
counterpart are they generally
because we're talking we're talking
about enterprises right this is it's an
important
part of the conversation so they rep
these are people that represent
you know there are change makers within
their respective organizations
and they work to you know to improve the
organization are they are they some
sort of champions of this idea of
agility
do they are they sort of like a star
like a startup mentality within the
enterprise or are they
just generally an executive that
understands okay we
we need to get going because we just
have to because the world is changing
i think there well yeah michael i think
there's a mix
there are folks who really have a vision
they know what they want to do what they
will know how they want to get there
and they appreciate where the
bottlenecks are for those the
conversation
from us as a service provider or vendor
is really
okay you know your pain points let us
deliver a solution or proposed solution
yet solve your pain points
there are others with this saying my
users are not happy my cost has to be
cut 20
what can you do right and for those
we go into a design discussion of say
what do you you know
where are you today and where are you
going and how do you deliver that
solution
so it really is it's a varied spectrum
there folks of course also say
actually i don't care i want this is my
spec
give me a bit i don't want to have any
discussion even
going into reverse auction and those are
interesting conversation because
hey i mean we will pay for those
business but oftentimes
the decision maker constrained
themselves in terms of
value they get right because if you say
i don't
i don't want to discuss you know any
levers i just want to get the same thing
as specified to cheapest
maybe your specifications are exactly
what you want but we don't get a chance
to discover that
so now so so what are some of the
leadership challenges that you might be
facing
as you know as a leader in that
situation as a change maker in that
situation
what are some of the challenges that you
might be right michael i think
usually most of the time we try to have
the proactive discussion
right um even if it's a pretty clear-cut
i want a box to shape this color we'll
have a conversation
of what you know what do you need to
achieve in your business
what are your current concerns and
bottlenecks because we can build you
exactly what you want but maybe we can
deliver it in a way that's more suitable
for your consumption
so as a change maker as an enabler
it's very important for us and for me
and my team to understand
where my customers need to go so we can
facilitate that only then i think we get
the
happiest customers and we have a lot of
content customers who get you know who
get the service they need
and go their merry way but i think the
most
the happiest customers are the ones to
have a productive
and open discussion of their needs and
we explore
a solution that meets their needs is
cost efficient
is agile and offer them sufficient
control
to uh to drive their own you know
directions in a more
technical level as well right and so and
so what
sort of skills do you you know as a
young entrepreneur
i'm thinking placing myself in that
situation what what skills
would a young entrepreneur need to
acquire throughout their journey in
order to
to get to a point where they can truly
listen to their customers they can truly
be adaptive and truly understand
and you know it sounds to me like
there's a lot of empathy involved in
this there's a lot of
uh you know relationship building that
is a part of this
what what skills are really critical
here yeah michael i think
it's important to have empathy and the
listening skills
uh because we are in the technology
business right
i keep saying that the business
objective is super important
but i think we got to put ourselves in
the shoes of the customers
as an entrepreneur i think you can
appreciate that hey what's your profit
and what's your loss
what's your cost right similarly they
have the same concern and they have the
business challenges if you're doing
consumer packaging
packaged goods and you have stuff stuck
in the warehouse because
due to lockdown things could not move
then what kind of you know
how would you want to optimize your cost
structure in this situation
and then we as a vendor how do we help
you design a solution that
can actually flex when you need i i
don't think
this example specifically applied to the
covet situation
and network per se but i'm trying to
cite an example where
uh beyond just listening uh there is the
technical background to understand that
hey
the product that you want to sell what
are the levers that you can tweak
right can you charge by the drink right
by consumption versus
you need the whole whole you know
shebang the contract sign you need the
whole payment up front
because be able to charge by consumption
allows you to much
offer much more flexible and customer
friendly
mechanism and and of course the ability
to allow them to control
based on their business needs is another
one that i think would be very helpful
but that does mean you got to build a
product that can enable that right
it's not just i have a product with 20
features or 200 features
it's a lot more than you need today is a
ferrari so you should pay me that
big chunk of money that you know out of
your cat bags
well right hardly any anyone would want
to do that today right they're gonna say
what's in it for me what's the day for
my business
right so it sounds to me that you know
as part of the complexity that you're
describing here is
is on one hand the flexibility but on
the other hand it's also
the simple idea that you know what
you're doing as a company
is not relevant for what the customer
needs you maybe the customer needs a
small
part of what you're doing as a company
you need to you need to
realize that your company and its
mission changes for every customer
and to be adaptive and to choose the
right suite of products the right suite
of features
but to also to price them accordingly
you're not
you know every customer is its own world
right that's what i'm hearing from you
yeah i i think so michael right but i
also want to caution that you're not
custom building something for everybody
right i mean i t architecture is
i think very complex because the needs
just gets more and more sophisticated
these days
become more software oriented i
look at this problem as a problem that
requires
composable solution right in the sense
that
if the customers it environment
enterprise environment needs
200 components take an extreme example
here
and i have a hundred of those yeah maybe
they want to buy all 100 for me that's
great right
but if maybe they only want to buy 20
from me and i have
i have to build my product in such a way
that it's easily pluggable right whether
it's apis or some type of interfaces
human interfacing that's easy to work
because
you want to build that relationship with
the customer you want to win that
business
maybe you can expand but you don't want
to create a situation where you don't
buy the whole thing from me i don't want
a business
because hey very few people have that
option of you know you take all
from me or you don't take anything from
me right
a song i want to thank you for joining
me in these 20 minutes it was really
really lovely
i do have some fun questions for you so
we'll get to those in just a second but
but i think it's really
interesting the outlook on you know
agility within enterprises and a lot of
times i got to talk to people that are
driving innovation within their own
organization but here also hearing from
the side of the enabler
who's helping them drive it i think
that's a really really fascinating
favorite subject in middle school or
high school
what would it be all right for me it's
uh physics
physics okay any particular type well so
that's the
slightly funny question the answer for
you because
i thought i like quantum physics and
cosmology but in high school obviously
you don't touch any of that i mean you
still on you know the
es equals mc square sounds great but you
don't study that
in high school so i was like hey i i
enjoy what i study here but i really
want to study
that stuff that's how i thought of it in
high school wonderful yeah
uh what who would be a role model of
yours
or somebody that serves as an
inspiration uh i think one of the
persons who
served as an inspiration for me was uh
richard feynman
he's a physicist right um noble lauren
amazing guy and i i really
enjoy reading about him right never met
him because by the time i think
i started college he's already passed on
and um
but you know he's a multifaceted guy
right he's not just a scientist
he got himself into all sorts of stuff i
remember reading about him being in
brazil
for a conference and he was stuck there
for
like a week or something or two weeks
and he decided to learn portuguese and
did a presentation in portuguese
just like that and you know what
amazing and you know renaissance man
and being able to learn and stretch and
extend and continue to be curious and be
having fun at the same time that's what
i thought
is very interesting yes i love that and
what are three words that you would use
to describe yourself
all right uh three words curious
analytical and persistent
curious analytical and persistent song
thank you very very much
uh thank you for being here i know how
busy you are i really appreciate it
and thank you for all the great insights
and your personal journey i really
appreciate it as well
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
michael really appreciate your time
thank you appreciate it thank you bye
[Music]